ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen zu
unserem ersten Stream im Jahr
2024 für viele Menschen in der Ukraine
dürfte es wohl ein furchtbarer sta ins
neue Jahr gewesen sein seit Tagen
überzieht Russland die Ukraine mit einer
massiven Angriffswelle weil dabei
offenbar gezielt Zivilisten und zivile
Infrastruktur angegriffen werden spricht
der ukrainische Präsident selenski und
sprechen viele Beobachter von
Terrorangriffen in der Nacht und am
frühen Morgen gibt heftige Explosionen
in der Hauptstadt Kiev Russland
attackiert die Ukraine massiv aus der
Luft dabei soll die russische Armee auch
mehrere hyperschallraketen einsetzen
neben Kiev wird auch hakiv massiv
beschossen die Ukraine meldet insgesamt
fün Tote und mehr als 120
Verletzte wir wollen heute fragen was
steckt hinter der aktuellen russischen
Angriffswelle warum beschießt Russland
offenbar aktuell gezielt Zivilisten und
zivile Infrastruktur t und wie kann und
wie müsste der Westen darauf reagieren
darüber spreche ich gleich mit dem
Militär und Sicherheitsexperten Nico
lange und wir schalten zu meiner
Kollegin Alisa jung Alisa wird uns
gleich zum einen von der Lage vor Ort in
Kiev berichten am Wochenende war sie
aber noch mit einem zdfteam in einem
Hotel in chakiv das von einer Rakete
getroffen wurde auch darüber wird sie
uns gleich erzählen eure Fragen und
Gedanken zum Thema könnt ihr wie immer
gerne direkt im Chat mit uns teilen oder
schickt sie uns per Mail an
zdfheute-live@zdf.de und ich versuche
dann wie immer möglichst viele davon
hier im Stream unterzubringen und an
unseren Experten
weiterzugeben und in München begrüße ich
unseren Experten jetzt und zwar Nico
Langel guten Abend nach
München h Herr Lange sie sind regelmäßig
hier bei uns zu Gast für diejenigen die
vielleicht jetzt noch nicht wissen wer
sie sind möchte ich sie einmal kurz
vorstellen sie sind militäranalyst bei
der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz haben
unter krkarrenbauer in führender
Funktion im Verteidigungsministerium
gearbeitet und sind ehemaliger Leiter
des kievbüros der Konrad Adenauers
Stiftung Herr Lange wir sehen jetzt
diese massiven Angriffe russischen
Angriffe auf die Ukraine aus der
Luft warum greift Russland die Ukraine
ausgerechnet jetzt auf diese Art und
Weise
an die Angriffe kommen leider nicht
überraschend man musste damit rechnen
dass Russland wieder das versucht was es
ja auch im letzten Winter versucht hat
nämlich ukrainische Infrastrukturen zu
zerstören Wasserleitung Stromleitung
Heizung
Heizkraftwerke Transformatoren diese
Dinge Russland fängt mit der
Angriffswelle deutlich später an als im
vergangenen Jahr und versucht damit
genau vor die kalten Tage zu kommen in
der Ukraine soll es jetzt kalt werden
und Russland hat Raketen produziert und
hat sie aufgespart um so große Wellen
von Angriffen zu Zeugen das ist das was
wir in der letzten Nacht und auch am 29
Dezember gesehen haben diese Wellen
braucht Russland weil die
Luftverteidigung der Ukraine
mittlerweile besser ist als noch vor
einem Jahr und man also ganz viele
kombinierte Raketen massflugkörper
Drohnen braucht um durchzukommen
das ist das was wir gerade sehen leider
muss man damit rechnen dass Russland
noch weitere solcher Wellen auf die
Ukraine loslassen wird wir bekommen dazu
auch schon fragen bei Youtube und zwar
unter anderem eine Frage nach der
Strategie also was verspricht sich Putin
denn von diesen Angriffen gezielt eben
auf Zivilisten und zivile
Infrastruktur na das Ziel ist
die Lebensbedingungen für die Menschen
in der Ukraine zu verschlechtern und
auch die Unterstützung für die
Streitkräfte geringer zu machen die
Industrie zu treffen also die
Rüstungsbetriebe die Munitionsfabriken
vielleicht auch die Instandsetzung für
Fahrzeuge und für Militärtechnik aber es
geht geht Putin auch darum Bilder ins
russische Fernsehen zu bringen die
zeigen dass er stark ist dass er in der
Ukraine etwas anrichten kann gerade
jetzt zu dieser Zeit wo während der
Feiertage rund ums Neujahr bis zum alten
neuen Jahr am 15 Januar die Russen ja
weitesgehend zu Hause sitzen und vor dem
fernseheren sie haben es angesprochen
also die die die russischen bodentroppen
die kommen gar nicht oder nur sehr
langsam voran z.B bei der Stadt afdfka
setzt die russische aktuell jetzt eben
verstärkt auf Angriffe aus der Luft weil
die Erfolge am Boden
ausbleiben zumindest gibt es nichts was
man vorzeigen kann aus russischer
Perspektive bei avdevka bei kupjans bei
bachmut an anderen Orten versucht
Russland schon seit einigen Wochen ganz
massiv anzugreifen kann aber keine
Städte erobern ein paar hundert Meter
geht's voran aber unter extrem hohen
Verlusten das sind natürlich keine
Bilder der Stärke und Putin braucht
Bilder die zeigen dass sein Krieg
irgendwie erfolgreich ist für Russland
in drei Monaten gibt's
Präsidentschaftswahlen in Russland das
sind zwar keine richtigen Wahlen und ist
auch klar dass Putin gewinnt wenn er
antritt aber trotzdem ist das für die
Stimmung in Russland ganz wichtig so
glaut Putin jetzt in der Propaganda
diese Bilder zu zeigen und Russland hat
ein spezielles Verhältnis zu seinen
Raketen es gibt Lieder die über Raketen
gesungen werden jeder kennt die Typen
von Raketen das wäre bei uns ja nicht so
der Fall also das ist auch ein Symbol
der russischen Militärmacht wenn man auf
andere Länder Raketen schießt eine Frage
zu diesen Raketen haben wir auch bei
Youtube bekommen und zwar wieso setzt
Russland diese Raketen nicht gegen
militärische Ziele ein was würden Sie
dazu
sagen ja Russland setzt diese Raketen
seit Beginn des Krieges gegen
Infrastrukturen ein aber ganz bewusst
auch immer wieder auf die Hauptstadt
Kiev auf hkev gerichtet damit die
Ukraine gezwungen ist die
luftverteidigungssysteme auch die von
uns gelieferten z.B ihres tslm oder auch
Patriot in diese Städte zu ziehen weil
dann hat Russland
die Möglichkeit an der Frontlinie
Luftangriffe zu fliegen die Ukraine kann
die
luftverteidigungssysteme dann nicht zum
Schutz der eigenen Truppe benutzen wenn
es damit die Städte und die Zivilisten
in den Städten benutzen muss äh das ist
glaube ich die ganz perfide Überlegung
auf der russischen Seite äh die Ukraine
militärisch auf diese Weise zu schwächen
wir haben jetzt auch in den vergangenen
Tagen die Darstellung gehört dass diese
Angriffe dies Angriffswelle eine
Vergeltung für einen angeblichen
russischen Angriff auf belgorot sein
soll sie haben jetzt aber schon gesagt
das ist jetzt nichts was man sozusagen
innerhalb weniger Tage plant und dann
durchführt sondern das ist was was
deutlich größerer und längerer Planung
Bedarf wie aufwendig ist es tatsächlich
eine solche Angriffswelle vorzubereiten
also mit diesen Angriffen musste man
leider rechnen und die Vorbereitung für
so eine Angriffswelle dauern sehr lange
denn es müssen nicht nur die
unterschiedlichen marflugkörper und
Raketen produziert werden das dauert
schon einige Zeit sondern die werden ja
von Schiffen aus dem Schwarzen Meer
gestartet von Flugzeugen über Belarus
von Flugzeugen über Russland über dem
Kaspischen Meer unterschiedliche
Flugzeuge unterschiedliche
Marschflugkörper die Routen müssen
programmiert werden die ganze Mission
wird geplant zeitgleich werden dann noch
drohen in den russischen in den
ukrainischen Luftraum gebracht also das
ist nicht etwas was man spontan als
Racheaktion über Nacht macht sondern das
ist systematische militärische Planung
die sehr langfristig erfolgt ist diese
Diskussion über eine vermeintliche
Racheaktion für belgorot ist glaube ich
eher ins Reich der Propaganda
einzuordnen aber leider muss man sagen
dass diese Propaganda immer wieder bei
uns hier funktioniert und dass Leute das
bei uns immer wiederholen ich glaube die
Russen selbst glauben weniger an die
russische Propaganda als einige Leute
bei uns das vielleicht noch weil sie es
auch noch mal angesprochen haben zu
belgorot als kleine Ergänzung falls das
in meiner Frage gerade missverständlich
war also Russland wirf der Ukraine
natürlich ein Angriff auf belgorot vor
das noch einmal zur Klarstellung
wir haben jetzt schon über die Techniken
also über die Raketen gesprochen es gab
jetzt auf Kiev auch Kiev war auch massiv
unter Beschuss von
Drohnen welche Erkenntnisse haben Sie
darüber was für Technik Kriegsgerät da
jetzt aktuell bei dieser Angriffswelle
eingesetzt
wird ja die Russen benutzen ja schon
länger shahiddohen und Weiterentwicklung
von diesen schahiddohen die aus dem Iran
stammen ursprünglich die sind jetzt
nicht besonders leistungsfähig die
Fliegen auch langsam und sind sehr laut
aber es gibt sehr viele davon und sie
sind billig und es geht glaube ich darum
die ukrainische Luftverteidigung immer
wieder heraus zufn und die Ukraine dazu
zu zwingen teure
luftverteidigungssysteme für billige
Drohnen zu verwenden die Kombination ist
das was es für die Luftverteidigung
schwierig macht also
kalibermschflugkörper die von Schiffen
gestartet werden
x 555 x55 x22 das sind alles Raketen die
von Bombern aus also von Flugzeugen aus
weit entfernt irgendwo über Russland
gestartet werden dann tausende Kilometer
fliegen und es gibt die kinjal Waffen
das sind sozusagen aufgemotzte
ballistische Raketen die von Flugzeugen
ausgestartet werden deswegen
hyperschallgeschwindigkeit erreichen
können die mit ganz geringer vorwandzeit
und na Selen sehr schnellen Flug dann
direkt auf Kier fliegen von einem vom
Luftraum über Belarus aus das ist nicht
weit weg also diese Kombination aus den
unterschiedlichen Systemen macht es für
die Luftverteidigung sehr sehr schwierig
sehr beeindruckend was die Ukrainer mit
diesen Systemen die sie ja auch
sozusagen zusammengepusselt haben aus
allem was sie geliefert bekommen haben
was sie sie damit leisten sind
vielleicht jetzt die erfahrensten und
besten Experten was Luftverteidigung
betrifft eine weitere Frage die wir bei
Youtube bekommen haben da fragt uns
jemand führt Moskau verstärkte Angriffe
aus der Distanz als Vorbereitung für
eine offensive durch oder weil man
aufkeimende Unzufriedenheit über die
hurentenverluste an Soldaten fürchtet
was würden Sie dazu sagen eher
letzteriss man braucht Bilder fürs
Fernsehen die Stärke demonstrieren und
in Russland ist das schon so wenn man
seine Raketen irgendwo hinschießt äh
dass die Leute da eher oder viele Leute
das eher toll finden und glauben dass
das russische Stärke zeigt eine
Vorbereitung einer Offensive ist das auf
keinen Fall Russland ist nicht in der
Lage größere offensiven zu führen wird
auch auf nächste Zeit gesehen nicht in
der Lage dazu sein die jetzt
bombardierten Städte also hakiv oder
Kiev mit einer Offensive anzugreifen man
sieht ja das was Russland offensiv
versucht nördlich von avdevka oder bei
kupjansk oder bei bachmut das hat
deutlich kleinere Dimensionen und
Russland kommt da ein kommt da zwar
voran aber ein paar hundert Meter unter
großen Verlusten also wir reden hier
nicht von großen militärischen Operation
Russlands die bevorstehen würden sie
haben jetzt schon gesagt dass diese
Angriffswelle dass das nichts ist was
man mal eben sozusagen aus aus dem
Bestand durchführt sondern diese diese
Raketen und Drohnen die mussten lange
sozusagen aufgespart werden
wie viel Nachschub um es mal platt zu
formulieren hat Putin denn tatsächlich
noch bzw wie lange wird er das
durchziehen können und wie viele dieser
Wellen die wir jetzt gerade erleben
werden wir in diesem Winter noch sehen
na
die russische Produktion insbesondere
von
marsflugkörpern war ja zwischendurch
einmal ins Stocken gekommen im letzten
Winter hat Russland viele Raketen
verschossen und auch aufgrund der
Sanktionen auch der technologischen
Sanktionen hat Russland viele
Bauteile z.B Mikrochips andere Dinge die
es nicht selbst entwickeln kann hat es
gar nicht aber in den letzten Monaten
hat Russland daran gearbeitet Sanktionen
zu umgehen Möglichkeiten zu finden über
Drittländer diese Dinge doch zu kaufen
und dadurch ist die Produktion an
marsflugkörpern wieder
gestiegen man kann davon ausgehen dass
Russland in der Lage ist im Monat von
diesen unterschiedlichen Typen dieser
mchlugkörper etwa 100 120 sich zu
produzieren also Russland braucht einen
Monat um die Raketen für eine solche
Angriffswelle zusammen zu bekommen die
Russen haben jetzt in den letzten
Monaten wenig Raketenangriffe gemacht
also Raketen produziert und aufgespart s
dass man davon ausgehen muss dass jetzt
in diesem Winter es waren jetzt zwei
solche Angriffswellen dass das russische
Material noch reicht um zwei oder drei
weitere solche Angriffe auf die Ukraine
durchzuführen höchstwahrscheinlich in
den nächsten Wochen während es in der
Ukraine sehr kalt sein wird Herr Lange
vielen Dank erstmal für den Moment wir
wollen gleich noch mal darüber sprechen
was die Ukraine diesen Angriffen denn
entgegensetzen kann und auch wie der
Westen ihrer Einschätzung nach darauf
reagieren sollte danke schön für den
Moment ja die russischen Angriffe die
Treffen aktuell verstärkt wieder
Zivilisten am Wochenende wurde in hakiv
auch ein Hotel getroffen in dem vor
allem Journalisten untergebracht waren
darunter auch ein Team vom ZDF um meine
Kollegin Alisa jung am Samstagabend
schlägt eine Rakete in rakiv im hakiv
Palace Hotel ein 15 Zimmer sind zu
dieser Zeit vermietet mindestens zehn
davon an Journalisten von unserem
zdfteam wird eine Dolmetscherin von
Trümmerteil getroffen und schwer
verletzt auch ein Sicherheitsmann wird
verletzt Alissa jung und ihr Team die
sind mittlerweile wieder in der
Hauptstadt Kiev und von dort ist Alisa
mir zugeschaltet hallo nach Kiev Alisa
hallo guten Abend vorab einmal wie geht
es Dir und wie geht es dem Team
aktuell uns geht es in Umständen
entsprechend gut ihr habt das gerade
vermeldet also zwei meiner Kollegen
wurden dabei verletzt eine Kollegin und
ein Kollege die Kollegin wird noch immer
im Krankenhaus behandelt der Kollege
wird ärztlich untersucht ist aber nicht
stationär im
Krankenhaus sie hat meine Kollegin
sedlana hat
schwere Verletzungen durch drümmerteile
in der Lobby bekommen sie war zu dem
Zeitpunkt des Angriffs in der Lobby ich
hoffe dass ihr Bilder zeigt weil man
kann sich das wahrscheinlich kaum
vorstellen wie das gewesen sein muss wir
waren also zu fünf zum Zeitpunkt des
Angriffs im Hotel drei von uns im
fünften Stock eine Kollegin in der Lobby
und ein Kollege im Elen Stock der durch
wie durch ein Wunder überlebt hat wenn
man sich das Gebäude anschaut und sieht
was für ein Krater entstanden ist beim
Einschlag der Rakete und sie sieht auch
wie dabei der elfte Stock getroffen
wurde ist es für uns alle immer noch ein
riesengroßes Wunder und fast
unbegreiflich wie er es geschafft hat
dabei nicht schwerer verletzt zu werden
das heißt natürlich das wirkt noch nach
diese Erfahrung wirkt noch nach und auch
die letzte Nacht war hier für uns in
Kiev natürlich keine ruhige sondern es
war wieder eine heftige Angriffswelle
bei der wir Schutz suchen mussten bei
der wir natürlich dann jetzt auch hoffen
dass uns sowas nicht noch mal passiert
weil das war natürlich für uns auch eine
unvorhergesehene Situation natürlich wir
sind im Kriegsgebiet nichtsdestotrotz
überlegen wir uns ja immer sehr genau wo
schlafen wir prüfen das im Vorfeld um
eben die Sicherheit des Teams zu
gewährleisten in dem Fall haben wir
dieses Hotel wie viele Journalisten und
NGO Mitarbeiter ausgewählt weil es einen
Bunker hat weil wir also uns dort auch
in den letzten zwei Jahren eigentlich
immer sicher gefühlt haben aber diese
mit dieser Sicherheit ist es nun vorbei
und so geht es natürlich hier allen
Menschen in der Ukraine täglich die hier
leben dann lass uns ger gerne noch
einmal auf Kiev schauen bitte also es
gab allein in der vergangenen Nacht
wieder massive Angriffe auf Zivilisten
und zivile
Infrastruktur wie ist die Lage in der
Stadt aktuell und wie geht's den
Menschen damit dass sie nun selber als
Zivilisten wieder verstärkt angegriffen
werden es gibt genau diese große Sorge
vor diesen möglichen noch kommenden
weiteren Angriffswellen die Nico lange
Gerade angesprochen hat denn dafür
scheint es ja auch noch Kapazitäten bei
der Seiten Russlands zu geben und genau
davor fürchtet man sich weil was hat man
für Möglichkeiten wenn so ein Angriff
kommt er passiert ja einfach irgendwo zu
welcher Zeit auch immer gerne in der
Nacht wenn man schläft das heißt also
hier sollen die Menschen MBE gemacht
werden das ist natürlich auch eine
Taktik die Menschen hier in ihrem Schlaf
permanent zu stören die Menschen nicht
schlafen zu lassen und was uns hier
viele Menschen auf der Straße berichtet
haben heute es sind folgende Aussagen wo
sind wir denn sicher sind wir auf der
Arbeit liegen wir im bet Bett sind wir
mitten auf der Straße gehen wir ins caff
sind unsere Kinder in der Schule es kann
jederzeit passieren und genau das ist ja
auch die Taktik dahinter dieses Gefühl
auszulösen ihr seid nirgendwo mehr
sicher ihr seid nirgends sicher und so
fühlt es sich an für viele Menschen hier
die Luftabwehr die leistet natürlich
großes aber es reicht eben nicht um alle
zu schützen das heißt es werden immer
wieder Menschen getreff verletzt immer
wieder Menschen getroffen und auch
getötet dabei und das löst hier
natürlich einfach große Angst große
Sorge aus bei allen dazu bekommen wir
auch eine Frage bei Youtube und zwar wie
wird der Krieg in der ukrainischen
Zivilgesellschaft aktuell bewertet davon
vielleicht noch von mir angeschlossen
was verändert denn die Heftigkeit der
Angriffe die wir jetzt gerade erleben
von denen du auch gerade berichtest an
den Forderungen nach mehr Unterstützung
durch den
Westen
Außenminister Kleber hat sich heute
geäußert und hat eben nach mehr
Unterstützung noch von den Verbündeten
im Westen hat noch mehr Unterstützung
gefragt mehr Unterstützung gefordert
eben ganz gezielt nach mehr
luftabwehrsystemen nach Drohnen aller
Art aber auch nach Raketen die eben eine
Reichweite von über 300 km haben damit
man sich eben verteidigen kann damit man
auch was entgegensetzen kann damit man
eben weiterhin irgendwie ein bisschen
Sicherheit gewährleisten kann die
Menschen hier schützen kann weil das was
Russland da ja zeigt ist ein Krieg gegen
Zivilisten gegen ziviles Leben es wird
von den Temperaturen her empfindlich
kälter auch in den nächsten Tagen in den
nächsten zwei Wochen das heißt wenn hier
auch der zivile Infrastruktur getroffen
wird dann heißt es natürlich auch für
die Leute es wird kalt und dunkel das
ist auch wieder Teil dieser
Zermürbungstaktik dieses Krieges gegen
die Zivilisten das heißt die Forderung
ist natürlich ganz klar wir wollen
geschützt sein irgendwie wie kann man
geschützt sein mit einer funktionierende
Luftabwehr die funktioniert hier in Kiev
besser als in anderen Städten in Städten
wie khakiv wo wir eben auch getroffen
worden sind die auch wieder letzte nach
Ziel waren ist die Grenze zu Russland
sehr nah das heißt auch die Zeit um sich
in Sicherheit zu bringen zu können sehr
kurz das heißt wir reden hier manchmal
nur von 6 Sekunden die man vielleicht
hat um sich in Sicherheit zu bringen man
kann sich ausrechnen je nachdem wo man
ist das reicht nicht und was bedeutet
das für die Menschen das bedeutet dass
sie entweder die Möglichkeit haben
permanent im Bunker zu leben ein Leben
im Bunker oder ihr Leben wie sie es
bislang ja auch gemacht haben stark und
resilient weiterzuführen aber
gleichzeitig mit dieser dauernden Angst
leben zu müssen ich könnte jetzt der
nächste sein die nächste
sein Alisa jung vielen Dank für deine
Eindrücke und für die einschz live aus
Kiev danke
schön wir wollen jetzt noch mal weiter
über die Unterstützung durch den Westen
für die Ukraine sprechen und das noch
einmal weiter vertiefen mit dem
Sicherheits und Militärexperten Nico
lange Herr Lange diese heftigen Angriffe
die wir gerade sehen wie kann die
Ukraine meine Kollegin hat jetzt gerade
noch mal die Luftverteidigung
angesprochen die in manchen Städten wie
Kiev z.B besser funktioniert als in
anderen wie kann sich die Ukraine
dagegen effektiv verteidigen
die Ukraine kann diese Angriffe
überhaupt nur überstehen weil sie
leistungsfähige
luftverteidigungssysteme bekommen hat
und die auch gut einsetzt dazu gehören
ja auch das deutsche IRS SLM aber auch
Patriot
nasams eine ganze Reihe von anderen
Systemen da haben die Partner der
Ukraine geliefert und tragen dazu bei
dass die Ukraine das überstehen kann äh
das ist keine hundertprozentigen Schutz
gibt bei Luftverteidigung das ist so
aber es ist schon sehr beeindruckend was
alles abgefangen wird trotz dieses
großen Aufwandes den Russland betreibt
wir sind alle gemeinsam etwas langsam
darin mehr von diesen Systemen zu
produzieren und auch mehr Lenkflugkörper
also Munition dafür zu produzieren da
muss die Industrie nachlegen oder die
zumindest müssen die Staaten dafür
sorgen dass die industriellen
Kapazitäten erhöht werden Putin macht ja
nicht den Eindruck dass er irgendwie vor
hat aufzuhören sondern ganz im gegen il
ersetzt darauf dass wir vielleicht
nachlassen oder nicht genug liefern man
darf sich aus meiner Sicht aber nicht
nur mit der Frage der Verteidigung
beschäftigen also für mich ist es
militärisch widersinnig dass man sagt ja
wir liefern Luftverteidigung und die
Ukraine muss die Raketen abwehren können
aber die Bomber also die Flugzeuge die
diese Raketen abfeuern irgendwo über
Russland und die dort von basenstaaten
oder die Schiffe im Schwarzen Meer die
darf man nicht angreifen also ich glaube
darüber sollte man noch mal nach denken
und man sollte auch darüber nachdenken
was hat das eigentlich für Folgen für
Vladimir Putin und für Russland wenn
jetzt Russland mehrfach die ukrainische
Hauptstadt heute früh als alle Leute auf
dem Weg zur Arbeit waren auf diese Art
und Weise angreift kostet das Putin
irgendwas oder zucken alle nur mit den
Schultern und sagen ja das ist halt so
also es muss Putin klar gemacht werden
aus meiner Sicht wenn er diese Angriffe
weiterführt dann werden neue Kategorien
von Waffen an die Ukraine geliefert dann
tun wir Dinge die bisher nicht getan
wurden damit er irgendeine Art von
Anreiz bekommt mit diesen Angriffen
aufzuhören also ich glaube einfach nur
zusehen wird nicht ausreichen Herr Lange
lassen Sie uns gleich darüber gerne noch
mal weiter sprechen angesichts der
russischen Terrorwelle werden auch hier
zu Lande Forderung laut die Ukraine eben
konsequenter zu unterstützen unter
anderem von Marie Agnes Strack
Zimmermann von der FDP sie ist die
Vorsitzende des Verteidigungsausschusses
im Bundestag wir konnten am nach Mittag
mit ihr sprechen und da hat sie
folgendes gesagt Deutschland macht sehr
sehr viel im Kreise der europäischen
Staaten am meisten aber richtig ist dass
die Angriffe massiv sind und
dass offensichtlich wir Angst vor unsere
eigigen Courage haben gemeinsam mit den
Partnern noch deutlich mehr zu machen
dazu gehört der
taurusmarschflugkörper mit dem die
Ukraine sehr wirkungsvoll die den
russischen Angriff zumindest
unterbrechen könnte und ja es ist in der
Tat so wir sind in einem neuen Jahr und
wir sollten nicht nachlassen und die
Worte wir sind an der Seite der Ukraine
solange Sie uns brauchen oder solange es
erforderlich ist das ist richtig aber
das heißt eben auch dass wir auch nicht
nachlassen dürfen die Ukraine zu
unterstützen mit allem was wir tun
können humanitär wirtschaftlich und eben
auch mit militärischer Unterstützung
heißt mit
Waffen also sie haben den Appell von
Marie Agne stagzimmermann gehört die
Entscheidung über eine weitere Lieferung
von Waffensystem wie z Z dem Taurus
marchw Körper die liegt im Kanzleramt
was erwarten sie von Olaf Scholz Herr
Lange wir tun noch nicht alles was wir
tun könnten und wir sind zu reaktiv das
heißt wir warten immer nur darauf dass
Putin etwas macht und dann langsam und
zögerlich darüber nachzudenken was wir
denn eigentlich jetzt tun wollen und
beides muss ich aus meiner Sicht im Jahr
2024 ändern Deutschland muss alles tun
was es tun kann kan gemeinsam mit den
europäischen Partnern das ist gerade
auch mit Blick auf die Entwicklung in
den USA notwendig und da geht's vor
allen Dingen um
industriekapazitäten Munition aber auch
um Wartung Instandsetzung von
Schützenpanzern Kampfpanzern die wir
schon geliefert haben und vor allen
Dingen und das ist der zweite Punkt
geht's darum mal aktiv zu überlegen was
können wir eigentlich noch machen und
nicht immer nur wenn wir gedrängt werden
und wenn es nicht mehr anders geht die
Zielstellung die Ukraine darf nicht
verlieren und wir un stützen solange es
notwendig ist ist aus meiner Sicht zu
wenig weil das das Rezept sein könnte
für einen sehr langen Krieg unter demem
die Ukrainer zu leiden haben Putin hat
offenbar keinerlei Absicht irgendwie
nachzulassen oder aufzuhören also muss
man ihn dazu bringen dass er aufhört und
nicht darauf setzen dass er irgendwann
irgendetwas einsieht und mit diesem
Krieg aufhört und dafür müssen wir die
Ukraine ausstatten ich glaube es beginnt
damit ganz klar das Ziel zu formulier
eren und spätestens jetzt zi Jahre nach
Kriegsbeginn muss endlich mal ein Ziel
formuliert werden das lautet die Ukraine
muss sich durchsetzen können militärisch
muss Russland aus der Ukraine vertreiben
und dafür müssen wir die Ukraine
ausstatten aber wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe das bedeutet ihrer Einschätzung
nach sollte Deutschland der Ukraine
Taurus marschlu Körper liefern ja
natürlich sollte Deutschland der Ukraine
taurusmschflugüberliefern die
Europäische Gemeinschaft die jetzt F16
Flugzeuge liefert könnte eine
Gelegenheit dafür bieten die Taurus z.B
auf die F16 Plattform zu integrieren um
dann gemeinsam mit anderen Europäern
diese wirkungsvollen Systeme einzusetzen
Taurus hätte aus meiner Sicht schon
lange vorbereitet werden müssen äh mit
der
plattformintegration mit der Ausbildung
äh um bereit zu sein für diese
Entscheidung damit nicht irgendwann wenn
dann nach ganz langer Zeit die
Entscheidung getroffen wird erst die
ganzen Vorarbeiten losgehen ich finde
das misslich dass über so Einzelsysteme
immer wieder diskutiert werden muss
Deutschland sollte überlegen was können
wir noch tun um die Ukraine dazu zu
bringen dass sie sich militärisch
durchsetzen kann und Taurus gehört ganz
eindeutig dazu dazu gibt's auch eine
Frage von KTI hütner die wir bei
Facebook bekommen haben also welche
militärischen Möglichkeiten sie ter lang
sehen Sie um die Souveränität der
Ukraine zu
bewahren russland hat doch seine
militärischen Ziele bisher nicht
erreicht ist doch nicht so dass wir
davon sprechen dass man da einer
besiegbaren Übermacht gegenüber steht
ganz im Gegenteil Putin muss sich
extremst anstrengen um mit so einer Art
primitiver sowjettaktik wo er ganz viele
Menschen wie Menschenmaterial an die
Front wirft ein paar hundert Meter
voranzukommen im Osten der Ukraine das
heißt wenn die Ukraine etwas mehr
modernes Material besser bessere
Technologien aus dem Westen hätte könnte
sie sich sehr wohl gegen Russland
durchsetzen es will ja auch niemand nach
Moskau marschieren oder Russland
irgendwie am Zeug fflicken sonder es
geht ja nur darum dass Russland aus der
Ukraine zurückgedrängt wird das ist
militärisch möglich aber dafür muss man
schneller und ähm mit industrieller
Unterstützung liefern und muss da auch
durchhaltefähig sein da geht's nicht um
Deutschland allein ich glaube da sind
die anderen europäischen Partner genauso
gefragt Frankreich Italien Spanien
können auf jeden Fall mehr machen machen
bisher auch weniger als wir aber das ist
jetzt die notwendige Überlegung ist
übrigens auch der einzige Weg wie man zu
einem Ende dieses Krieges kommen kann es
kann doch nicht unser Rezept sein zu
sagen wir liefern immer ein bisschen
damit die Ukraine irgendwie überlebt und
der Krieg geht dann ewig auf diese Art
und Weise weiter Herr Lange wenn wir
jetzt über die verstärkte Unterstützung
sprechen und auch über z.B die Lieferung
von Taurus die das Argument in der
Debatte um die Lieferung von Taurus war
ja bisher dass man sozusagen nicht
möchte dass die Ukraine damit
gezielt Ziele auf russischem
Staatsgebiet
angreift wie sehen Sie das das wäre
damit ja sozusagen eine Position von der
mal abweichen müsste na ich halte das
Argument im konkreten Fall von Taus für
vorgeschoben die Ukraine hatte das nie
vor
äh man kann das auch durch technische
Dinge ausschließen hätte man schon lange
vorbereiten können das ist wenn man
etwas nicht will dann erfindet man
Argumente um es nicht zu tun wir sehen
doch was die Ukraine mit skypej und mit
stormshadow also den ähnlichen mkörpern
aus Frankreich und Großbritannien macht
und es geht darum die Logistik der
Russen und das Aufmarschgebiet auf der
auf der Krim zu stören den nachtschub
über die Brücken abzuschneiden das ist
militärisch ganz unbedingt notwendig
niemand will mit diesen marsflugkörpern
Taurus irgendwelche Ziele in Russland
angreifen mal abgesehen davon
äh muss man aber die Grundsatzfrage äh
ist das eigentlich sinnvoll äh dass die
Ukraine sich sozusagen Zusammenschießen
lassen soll aber die Militärbasen von
denen die bomberstaten und die Schiffe
die die Raketen abfeuern nicht angreifen
soll äh also das muss man schon
hinterfragen ob das sinnvoll ist
völkerrechtlich sind militärische Ziele
innerhalb Russlands auf jeden Fall
völlig legitim anzugreifen durch die
Ukraine wenn sie überfallen worden ist
wenn wir noch mal auf die
Waffenlieferung schauen haben wir eine
Frage bekommen von Mario bei Youtube und
zwar was sind eigentlich was sind die
eigentlichen Hintergründe warum die
westliche Rüstungsindustrie nicht in
Klammern so schnell hochläuft wie das
nötig und wie auch Russland das macht
welche Erklärung haben sie
dafür Industrie braucht lange Zeiträume
und Vorlaufzeiten also wenn man sagt wir
brauchen mehr luftverteidigungssysteme
oder mehr Munition für diese Systeme
dann muss man sehr lange planen und
Kapazitäten aufbauen bis dann am Ende
mehr herauskommt das ist in der Politik
glaube ich nicht immer verstanden was
für lange Zeiträume das braucht deswegen
ist das so wichtig frühzeitig mit den
Vorbereitungen zu beginnen und die
Industrie muss sich natürlich darauf
verlassen können dass diese
Investitionen auch finanziiert sind und
da gibt es insbesondere in Deutschland
aber ich glaube das gilt für andere
Staaten auch zu wenig Vertrauen dass die
finanziellen Zusagen am Ende auch
eingehalten werden und wenn man sich
anguckt dass aus 2% des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts die für
Verteidigung ausgegeben werden sollten
plus 100 Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen
jetzt im Haushalt
2024 sowas wie 2% na ja aber für ein
Jahr und nur durch das Sondervermögen
und danach weiß man nicht wie es
weitergeht mit den Finanzen geworden ist
kann man das auch ein bisschen
nachvollziehen andere Staaten wie z.B
die USA die geben ihrer Industrie
Abnahmegarantien und sagen für die
nächsten 5 Jahre oder für die nächsten
10 Jahre kaufen wir alles was ihr
produziert und dadurch haben die
Unternehmen eine Sicherheit zu
investieren Leute einzustellen neue
Kapazitäten aufzubauen also über solche
Dinge nach nachzudenken gehört glaube
ich in Deutschland zur zeitenwender auch
dazu also sie fordern einen
Strategiewechsel mit Blick auf die
militärische Unterstützung der Ukraine
was glauben Sie denn wie realistisch ist
das dass sich da tatsächlich auf
absehbare Zeit was
ändert ja ich mag nicht darüber
spekulieren was realistisch ist ich kann
aber sagen was notwendig ist und
notwendig ist die Ukraine langfristig
industriell unterlegt zu unterstützen
und nicht erst wenn man sozusagen
aufgewacht ist weil Putin nichts
einsieht sondern den Krieg immer
weiterführt plötzlich hektisch zu
versuchen noch Dinge rumzureißen man
sieht ja wie das bei der
munitionsproduktion für die
Artilleriemunition leider nicht geklappt
hat nur eine Millionen Schuss zu
produzieren ich finde das peinlich für
führende Industrienationen ich glaube
ein Problem an der ganzen Sache ist aber
auch dass man gar nicht so genau weiß
wer ist denn eigentlich jetzt derjenige
oder die enige die sich den ganzen Tag
nur mit der Frage beschäftigt wie kann
man der Ukraine weiterhelfen wie kann
man diese Dinge in die Hand nehmen also
man kann doch so einen Krieg nicht wie
einen Vorgang von vielen managchen und
sich immer nur damit beschäftigen wenn
man gerade kapazitätenfrei hat oder wenn
gerade etwas akutes passiert also da
fehlt es ein bisschen an Systematik und
ein Strategie das wäre gut wenn das im
Jahr 2024
endlich Einzug hält weil ich keinerlei
Hinweise darauf se
dass Putin irgendwie gewillt ist mit
diesem Krieg aufzuhören oder einzulenken
oder irgendwie weniger zu machen also
kommt es darauf an dass wir ihm eine
langfristige Strategie entgegensetzen
Herr langer ich möchte Ihnen gerne
abschließend noch eine Frage stellen die
wir bei Youtube bekommen haben die geht
jetzt sehr weit in die Zukunft ich
möchte sie aber trotzdem nicht unter
Tisch fallen lassen und zwar ab wann
können wir denn grob mit einer
ukrainischen Luftüberlegenheit
rechnen ja eine
Luftüberlegenheit auf dem gesamten
Gebiet der Ukraine wird aus meiner Sicht
keine der beiden Seiten mehr erreichen
können dazu ist das gesamte Land im
Grunde auf beiden Seiten der Front mit
hochleistungsfähigen
luftverteidigungssystemen viel zu sehr
gesättigt
äh das kann keiner mehr schaffen aber
lokale Luftüberlegenheit um z.B Truppen
am Boden etwas zu entlasten die könnte
die Ukraine herstellen sobald die F16 im
Einsatz sind an bestimmten
Frontabschnitten äh das halte ich auch
für wichtig insbesondere im Süden und
gerade dort glaube ich dass die Ukraine
Chancen hat auf künftige
Luftüberlegenheit dann mit den F16 wenn
die weitreichende Munition für die F16
auch zur Verfügung gestellt wird weil
die Ukraine dort Radare
luftverteidigungssysteme Schiffe die
Luftverteidigung haben systematisch
ausgeschaltet hat mit spezialoperationen
und auch mit Präzisionswaffen und im
Grunde ganz gut vorbereitet ist auf
diese nächste Phase dann ab dem Frühjahr
also da könnte das Gelingen insgesamt
ähm wird das keinem gelingen und der
letzte Punkt vielleicht noch zur
Luftüberlegenheit was der gesamte
Kriegführung sehr stark verändert ist
der massenweise Einsatz von drohen nicht
nur jetzt drohen die in Infrastrukturen
fliegen sollen sondern massenweise
drohen direkt über dem Kampfgebiet äh
und auch das verändert für
Luftverteidigung und für
Luftüberlegenheit die militärischen
Überlegungen sehr stark das erwähne ich
deswegen weil ja abgesehen von dem was
da in der Ukraine passiert auch die
Frage sehr wichtig ist was lernen wir
eigentlich daraus und ich glaube die
Bundeswehr aber die Streitkräfte
generell in der NATO müssen aus diesem
massenweisen Einsatz von drohen äh sehr
sehr viele Lehren ziehen vor allen
Dingen muss man sich billige
Möglichkeiten zur Abwehr von drohen
überlegen weil man mit teuren äh
luftverteidigungssystemen die begen
Drohnen nicht dauerhaft wird bekämpfen
könen Nico lange Sicherheitsexperte und
militäranalyst bei der mönchner
Sicherheitskonferenz vielen Dank für das
Gespräch und für ihre Einschätzung heute
Abend
gerne ja das war unser ZDF heute live
zur aktuellen Angriffswelle in der
Ukraine wie immer findet ihr
Hintergründe und aktuelle Infos zum
Krieg in der Ukraine in unserer ZDF
heute App danke euch für heute fürs
zuschauen für eure ganzen Fragen und bis
zum nächsten
Mal